smes at the same time the greatest challenge is
the greatest potential for growth
when these places
[Music]
the 2009 artificial intelligence activation program
offers coats
of two to four months therefore
more beautiful mandates easier to integrate to
be quick to  a small medium
-sized company we are really looking to start
a dia project a dia reflection in
a company, particularly with
Quebec SMEs our role is to
help them work and lived for a
few months to really
understand where lio could make a star because
that when my name is a company in a
project in which we think we read it
allows us to be more competitive both
locally and
internationally
[Music]